on the hill today for the indians it'll
be logan allen allen the left-hander 6-3
220 pounds now a standing ovation for
carlos santana
helmet comes off santana waves it to the
crowd both at third and first
and a well-deserved standing ovation for
a guy that had a heck of a run with the
cleveland indians
the pitch swung on tamper to the mound
allen looks at second now a good throw
to first
and gets carlos santana for out number
two and you had to think
santana after that rousing ovation
really wanted to deliver the base hit
there and maybe a little bit anxious
and a big shot here for
michael a taylor who already
has driven in six
allen back slightly turned to the hitter
sets
and delivers
a swing and a mess he got him with a
slider
logan allen gets out of it
leaving the royals all over the joint
kansas city loads them up logan allen
strikes out michael taylor kansas city
doesn't score the indians coming to bed
k.c will counter with veteran
left-hander danny duffy
beginning his 11th major league season
and that will bring up jose ramirez
ramirez the american league mvp
runner-up a season ago boy what a year
he had
in the shortened season
he's third in the league and doubles
homers runs batted in
swaying a chopper up the middle fielded
by merrifield touches second goes to
first double play
nicely done by whit
and the royals get out of any trouble in
the first inning we head to the second
nothing nothing score
those score ending number two top of the
order
with lopez
a base stealer at first two down in the
second with mary field line to single to
center his first time up
that is crushed to left field and whit
merrifield goes up into the bleachers
way up into the bleachers
on a 3-0 pitch
allen knew it perez knew it and whitney
and the royals get two at two outs in
the second inning
witt maryfield with his third home run
and now eight rbis
in the first four games of the season
two on two gone for josh naylor another
left-handed batter duffy looks to the
runner at second now the pitch
swing and a ball hit to left field
coming in benetendi
looked like he might have lost in the
lights for a second but he was able to
find it make the catch and in the inning
and the royals continue to shut out
cleveland as we go to winning number
five here's roberto perez to lead things
off at the bottom of the fifth inning
duffy deals off speed pitch hit to right
field and it's going to be caught by
solaire he went down to one knee and
made a
fine catch
for route number one
royals up two to nothing enhancer
alberto
playing at third today as hunter dozier
missing his third straight game
with that jammed right thumb
alberto one for two of the single
the right-handers pitch
swung on line towards short diving
backhanded grab by rosario
rosario diving toward third with a
backhanded snag
so he takes a hit away from hansar
alberto bottom of the sixth coming up
royals two indians nothing
here's eddie rosario
for two with a foul out to the catcher
and a fly out to center
lefty lefty
three and two duffy's 97th pitch
is on the way and a swing and a miss and
he struck him out on a fastball down
five strikeouts through six scoreless
innings for duffy who's retired
seven in a row we go to the seventh
royals on top two nothing barry field
has singled hit the two run homer to
left on a 3-0 pitch in the second
then grounded out
now the pitch
and a fastball hit high in the air into
shallow center coming in his loop low
he will make the catch mcbroom tags he's
coming home here's the throw it's cut
off and an rbi for whitmer field his
third on the day the royals lead it
three nothing and whitmerfield has
driven in all three runs
fran mill reyes has lined out to the
warning track in center and double
right-hander against right-hander
once again the indians
much like the series in detroit just not
able to get anything going offensively
barlow 6-3 2-10 in his first victorias
lined on a hop to short diving stop by
lopez he throws to first for the out
nikki lopez diving to his left and
making a good play to take a hit away
from fran mill reyes for the first out
of the inning
two out nobody on here's michael a
taylor walked his last time up
that was facing mackenzie
down line drive basic
cut off by
eddie rosario oh he's he is in no man's
land where was he going i wonder
well he just figured he was going to
continue to run to you tag them
and they will
thank you
the inning is over
michael taylor got a base hit and then
ran himself into the third out in the
inning
it's the middle of the eighth three
nothing royals
and now out of the bullpen comes james
caron check to face andrew benintendi
lopez at second mary field at first two
down in the kansas city ninth royals
leading 3-0
now the o2
checked on a curve did he go appeal at
third he went
perez picks it up tags out ben and tendy
and karen jack with a big strikeout
to end what could have been a disastrous
ninth inning
so the indians have one more shot
they've got the guys they want coming to
the plate two three and four in the
order but the royals lead three nothing
going to the bottom of the ninth
and the indians bring the tying run to
the plate in eddie rosario
infield playing him with the pull same
with the outfield
here's the pitch
curveball hit on the ground fielded by
santana goes to second for one on the
first double play
what an excellent throw by carlo santana
and the last hope is fran mill reyes
on nudge yes for the sign
now brings the 1-2
hitting the ground off of jesse he picks
up the baseball throws to first in time
and the royals with a three-nothing
victory
merrifield the star of the game driving
in all three runs with a two-run home
run and a sacrifice fly and great
pitching today from
danny duffy scott barlow and jesse hahn
the royals win it three nothing